welcome back to las vegas now as people
get their taxes prepared we checked in
with eric palacios of eric palacios and
associates the sponsors of this next
segment to learn more about tax fraud
and how to prevent it check it out
hey eric welcome back
hi thanks for having me always good to
see you it's time to get an update on
taxes tax season is underway
tax fraud we are all vulnerable to it
let's talk about it what exactly is that
uh tax fraud is when you deliberately
misrepresent uh what you've earned when
you try to hide income earnings or
assets uh then you can get in trouble
with the irs right so what are the
penalties exactly what happens
they can be pretty harsh uh up to a
hundred thousand dollar fine up to five
years in prison uh if you are operating
as a business as a corporation then the
fine can be up to five hundred thousand
dollars wow and if the irs you know is
involved how do they know how to audit
people or how do they know who is to be
audited
uh it's a computer uh software that they
use and it looks for irregularities in
tax returns so if you're flagged uh you
will receive a letter from the irs this
is very important there's a lot of scams
going on if you get an email if you get
a phone call saying you need to pay or
we're going to come to your house we're
going to come to your business and
arrest you uh that's not the irs that's
not how they operate they simply send
you a letter scheduling uh face-to-face
meeting or asking you to call them that
is a great reminder a great you know
warning so if someone is audited should
they be afraid how should they react
what should they do first things first
uh yes and no it is a a scarier or an
intimidating uh process but as long as
you've done everything correctly you
shouldn't be afraid to go and talk to
them it's important that you take all
your proof all your documentation all
your receipts and what's going to happen
is they're going to go through that and
if they do find that you uh miss some
items or that you should have paid some
normally you won't get in too much
trouble you will just have to pay the
difference the amount that you owe
interest and maybe a penalty
okay but when should you be worried if
you're audited you should worry if you
deliberately did something you know you
couldn't have done if you hit assets you
hit
income or earnings or you exaggerated
your expenses if you don't have
documentation to back up uh what you
claim on your taxes then you should
worry yeah you did not get you did not
get away with it this is actually what's
happening there um what should you do to
prevent being audited
it's important to have a good tax
preparer if you're running a business
it's important to have a cpa a
bookkeeper
an enrolled agent
if you're just employed by someone and
you have a relatively simple uh tax tax
return it's still a good idea to have
someone you trust help you in preparing
your taxes and always be honest don't
exaggerate uh trying to get a bigger tax
return that's going to bite you in the
end
always be honest integrity what a
concept that is great advice
thank you to eric palacios and
associates for sponsoring that important
segment give them a call at 702-444-7777